we're going to talk about measuring
latitude and longitude we'll just do it
in order so we'll do latitude first then
we'll do longitude so what we're going
to do is put a couple of us put a couple
of parallels of latitude on here and
then we're going to draw parallel TPR
how about you besides we are another
diagram that's going to help us work it
and work this out okay so if you got
some colors what I want to do is let's
draw a small circle a pound of latitude
somewhere up here make it nice and high
and then label a spot line we'll call
this kind of paper and then look for
another one let's put it a bit closer
this time down the bottom here
and again label spot about that's called
cube okay now I've put a P and Q right
on the edge but you really can put P and
Q anywhere on that ladder - you already
wrote this letter to you but bigger just
make it a bit easier for us to visualize
now what I wanted to do is to take this
sphere and slice it right down from the
top to the bottom from the north to the
South Pole so instead of looking at a
sphere now we're looking at a
cross-section of the sphere and it's got
the center in there okay now you'll
notice I've got the center of course put
this red peril of latitude on it which
is really important what special about
this one is the equator now the reason
why we have one of them is more
important than the others is we need a
point of reference from which we can
measure so you've got to Center here
remember
we sliced across slice across so now
we're looking at a cross-section so that
great circle the equator now is kind of
directly horizontal okay there'd be
equator right there yes he sat down -
okay now from the equator if you have a
look at these other two spots that we
draw I've got P which is north of the
Equator so up here quite high and then I
have Q which is south of the Equator
and I do that a little bit closer now in
order to describe where each of these
points are one flock that looks down I
just start from the middle and then I go
up or down
so for example to go up to this guy here
I would measure it in what angle look
like you guys just take your up this 45
yeah i okay so the video that we were
forced into one so if that were 50
degrees so what I'm measuring to is the
equator then I would call the latitude
of this 50 degrees not okay that
latitude and everywhere automatic
parallelization has a measured as 50
degrees or this guy down here by
contrast is a little bit high so much
for that maybe another 15 15 degrees so
this guy is below the equator so I would
say that's 15 degrees so okay now I said
before the tropics of cancer and
Capricorn those are really important
parallels of latitude so it's probably
worth noting what the car right here the
tropic of cares are actually really easy
to remember it's 23 points for I mean
there's definitely is twenty three point
four degrees north and the Tropic of
Capricorn is twenty three point four
degrees south so it's worth pointing out
that both of these are movies at both
moving because the earth kind of doesn't
just stay in exactly the same position
it's sort of we will do a little bit and
it doesn't stay stable so these are the
changes but right now there's another
time I mean if you told things
you we told the closet Commissioner look
then um I'm pretty sure when I was your
age even 23.5 pretty sure but again I'm
looking I'm thinking back to a long time
ago okay well we originally measured
them what were they I actually don't
know a lot if you could find out
let's go season it okay so from your
campus to the kids on top of your
pectoralis major now let's take a nap
luggage shoes right so again remember
there is one of the wandering Corian
what as long as you there's what am i
okay there's one of them are really
hasn't wanted to this board ones of the
wrist which is a primary appointment
which passes to Greenwich so again we're
going to put that guy so I like to put
the genius for edge way to Center that's
what you follow up with one of them I
believe great on there and label that as
the prime do really was a great so it is
without Greenwich it is not brain which
agree watch this anyway you know if
English is great so just like the
equator or is actually with you the
equator is not a normal sound so what do
you think it's latitude would be there
is it exactly the same way the prime
grid is zero degrees longitude and again
if we cut the circle CR so we've got a
circle after the opposition let's do
some points on here let's pick some
points up you remember they're all going
to be great circles so they're all going
to pass through the North and South
Poles so this is hard to visualize where
you've got to see because all of these
great circles are intersecting with each
other at the poles so when we cut this
open sorry
what we're going to do in addition to
cutting it like this I'm actually going
to chop the top off okay so you're going
to get something like this it's like a
bowl okay you've got to set up right
there
I've cut through the equator as well so
where is the Prime Meridian
well preachers in the rural inhibitive
cutoff but I can draw the Prime Meridian
still easier there's a sample down there
so now when I look at say the longitude
of P you can see piece of this way it is
each of the primary you east of the
Prime Meridian so if I carry its Great
Circle down it looks like it's somewhere
like that right so this is the Meridian
the P is on so that I can't see Taylor
is in the northern hemisphere but that's
okay
you can see I'm going to measure from
the set up to the rear and I'm going to
compare it we British so I've got angles
here at the center
okay let's call out 40 degrees okay so
if you start already and then you go 40
degrees east now you have the longitude
of everywhere on this great circle let
me say that again wherever on the region
if you start with the Prime Meridian
aggressor and then you rotate through 40
degrees to get to this Meridian where P
is that would make it 40 degrees east
because that's the direction you know I
had rotated if on the other hand what is
free you've got this guy over here which
is just west of the primary input this
way right
just a teeny little bit let's call that
an objective reason something with that
this is a degrees in the other direction
is Q so it could be 8 degrees
okay so I just like we mentioned before
the equator is zero so Greenwich of
course which is known that east or west
of itself is going to be different okay
now let me show you it's using BB enough
of bad yes I see that now
it's pretty tiny it's pretty tiny but if
you squid super super super hard if you
want let me write it there for you cuz I
don't expect a bit let's do a lot of
time so under where you've got the
Tropic of Cancer and the Tropic of
Capricorn CCHS north and south
what are we we talk without power
without where is it that's the right
hemisphere the number of reading of
there is 33 degrees and it says 43
minute us and not accuracy me 33 degrees
43 minutes which means by the way just
with sounds of the Tropic of Capricorn
which means what we're not direct
members which means at midday this day
no matter what season it is the Sun is
never going to be exactly directly
overhead okay because we're ballooning
so that's when we are in terms of
latitude
what about luggage you again hunter USD
one degree yeah but you shifty one and
it's
and we are one I say we must remember
when I rotated around where each try let
me get the globe again your food guys
we're just you're doing on here see area
here we go
see we are right or hot ways there we
are
yeah so if you come back home to
Greenwich Greenwich
there's better can't you see I'm tempted
on England instead and right here you go
okay so you can see I want to go to the
east I've got to go easy steep I almost
had to go all the way around I always
have to go all the way how many degrees
when I have gone if I went all the way
around I'm gonna hug late but you can
see if I come back to this guy if you're
lucky okay way to go we're going to look
there we go so can you see the pod
Rhydian can you see where it is and then
I'm going to go eat now
so East off we go until I get to here
and you can see I almost get 280 right
there's 180 the opposite side of the
brilliant is that
listen